here now will kane co-host the fox
friends weekend and host of the will
kane podcast and then you got my friend
ainsley earhardt co-host of fox and
friends thank you all so much for
joining me tonight will uh you been out
front on this make it make sense for me
brother
what do i have a master's in
interpretive dance i'm supposed to make
that make sense lawrence that was an
amazing piece of gold you found to play
as video and it probably sums up what
ainsley and i could struggle to do in
five minutes that this whole thing is
nonsense but here's what i would say
it's worse than nonsense lawrence it's
child abuse it is not tent amount to
child abuse it is child abuse after two
years where we know there is isolation
depression
loss of learning and and increasing risk
of suicide what we have watched is a
society who takes its most vulnerable
its children and to add on top of that
lawrence disproportionately it's black
and brown children to the top of the
volcano and toss them into the fire we
have sacrificed our children at the
altar of fear and power and all the
other ugly human sins in the chicago
teachers union who knows what they want
lawrence i don't know what they want
money power all i know all i know is
they do not want what is best for our
children
you're so right ainsley you spent part
of your time going out there and talking
with parents and they wanted to get back
to school and we were promised if we
give the teachers first priority when it
comes to the covet shots and if we give
them this money
to redo the classroom so they can have
great ventilation system that they will
return
but when they got this money they used
it for crt and other social justice
programs
that makes everyone so angry
i mean lawrence they got a hundred and
thirty billion dollars for the american
rescue plan to reopen schools they got
the money why are the schools closing
again we've almost experienced this for
two years parents are frustrated when we
go out to have the conversations with
parents in different counties like
loudoun county they are furious some of
them have children with emotional issues
and they don't know how to teach them at
home two years of being at home or a
year and a half or even a year being at
home back in back at home virtually not
in the classroom in front of teachers
that are trained to teach these kids
think about the little ones the loss of
learning they're trying to learn to read
they're wearing masks and and they can't
see the teacher's mouths and that's one
thing i'm fine if we have to wear the
masks in order to get back into school i
can live with that i just want our
children back in school and and to your
point you are absolutely right it is the
the lower class it is the minority
children that are really affected by
this because many of them don't have the
tools to go virtually at home and that's
exactly what the surgeon general was
saying yesterday so why are they
teaching crt where are the priorities
and guess who guess who is is uh suffers
because of this our children you listed
all those cities with crt it also us
california is using that money for crt
new york buffalo washington state
massachusetts minnesota oregon nevada
rhode island and and the list goes on
and on and lawrence i'm old school i
want math and science i want reading i
want uh computers taught to my daughter
i don't want all the crt stuff if
there's money left over down the road
then we can talk about teaching equity
and all of that in our classrooms
because i do believe all children are
equal in the eyes of god but i want the
golden rule taught and i want those i
want math and science i want all of that
taught to my daughter we only have them
for 18 years before we send them off to
college and that's not a lot of time
when you consider vacations in summer
months when they're not learning at all
that's exactly right well we learned
from kova that a lot of people don't
want to go back to work a lot of them
were forced to go back to work because
the man don't work he don't eat they
needed money but the teachers unions
they don't have to work and they still
get paid
that's right you know what this is
lawrence it's a work stoppage it's a
work stoppage it's a strike under the
guise of remote learning truthfully what
it is is it's child abandonment they've
abandoned our children they've abandoned
it against all science and data you and
ainsley went through that list of
schools that devoted money to crt
training milwaukee virginia atlanta la
dc does it strike you that it's the very
same schools that today have voted to go
remote for at least some period of time
it seems that the only thing our school
districts and many of these cities are
willing to teach is how our children
should turn into racists because i
disagree with ainsley on one semantic
thing i believe in equality i don't
believe in equity equity is a trojan
horse through which they they implement
marxist ideology and neo-racism equality
is a common human goal
and i'm not going to stand right
no and answer it's a small correction
that you know but here's why it's
important ainsley because i think many
people semantically um confuse the two
and that's how they they guide many
people along on this ideological move
and i'll just stay with this in the end
lawrence this is the important point i
want to make the new york times the
other day sort of admitted to all of
this they admitted to how bad it's been
i don't know if you saw the article how
bad this has been for our children all
of these shutdowns and it's too little
too late new york times at this point i
want accountability i want
accountability from the politicians the
pundits the cable news hosts i want
accountability from the teachers unions
and the media you cannot punish children
and get away with it
you know ainsley i'll give you the final
word because a lot of in that article a
lot of the columnists that that tweeted
out said they didn't know
are you kidding me did you not see the
kids
you know lawrence i want to know why
this was allowed to be used for crt this
was supposed to be used for testing for
ventilation for masks for whatever it is
to get our kids back in the classroom
not for crt and they pass this under the
guise of public health and many of those
issues those crt issues they're saying
are public health issues baltimore there
are two high schools recently that were
studied and not a single student is
proficient in these high schools not a
single student in math or science yet
they're probably learning crt so why use
this money for crt our children are
suffering
you're exactly right can we just answer
that really quickly can i give one hint
on that lawrence hey ainsley i'm sure
you both saw the news within the past
week the governor of new york kathy
hokel has declared racism a public
health crisis therein lies how you can
divert money away from actually putting
children back into the classroom and
devote it to crt that is the new
standard everything will be public
health to get what they want and if
we're stupid enough to fall for it the
shame on us but the kids deserve better
ainsley will thank you
for joining me tonight hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else